so etwas findest du gut dann kannst du
den fußboden aber zwölf kilometer hinter
dir saubermachen mit dem was ist daher
das alter guck mal wie lange das ist ein
leute was glaubt willkommen bei einem
neuen video
o
musikunterricht gemacht da müssen wir
das möglichst lange halten um die
stimmen männer anzuregen
was gedacht und jetzt willkommen bei
einer video habe jetzt schon zum zweiten
mal gesagt heute geht es um etwas was
ihnen bevor gestanden habe und zwar habe
ich irgendwann mal auf youtube gefragt
ja auch was für videos und indie rock
und viele haben da diese seite
aliexpress vorgeschlagen können sie das
können sie mir das ist nämlich eine
seite da gibt es alle möglichen sachen
also auch wirklich alles mögliche das
zeug kommt aus deutschland china spanien
frankreich und der usa sind so die haupt
produktionsländer ich glaube deutschland
gar nicht so unbedingt und wider von
euch haben gesagt ich soll doch mal so
eine hochzeit edition machen ja das hört
sich jetzt dumm an aber es geht wirklich
darum dass wir heute vielleicht mal so
nennt sich das hochzeitskleid oder halt
so ein hochzeitsanzug bestellen weil das
ding ist da gibt es so eine große
auswahl da gibt es ist wohl das meiste
ist halt echt günstig das heißt im
endeffekt testen wir dann mal so ein
hochzeitskleid für keine ahnung 50 euro
oder 2 hochzeitskleider für 50 euro und
so ein anzug weil normalerweise wenn man
heiratet also das soll jetzt so nicht
worüber ich will ja keinen heiraten oder
so wir schauen einfach war wie teuer
mitreißenden brautkleid wenn man so sich
ein kauf des fonds schon 2000 2004 ohne
braut brautkleid ja und wo steht ihr
jetzt wird den preis also muss ich denn
jetzt die nachricht schreiben wie teuer
kostet euro scheins kleid ich finde
nichts wir gehen jetzt einfach mal davon
aus ein brautkleid kostet so um die
keine ahnung 1500 euro sein weil es ist
ja schon relativ ihre und das muss ja
auch immer dann der bräutigam bezahlt
also leute das ist die seite die mir
sehr viele von euch vorgeschlagen haben
ich war hier schon einmal kurz drauf und
hab mich ein bisschen umgeschaut habe
zum beispiel nach schuhen geschaut das
wird mehr cdu vorgeschlagen zum beispiel
diese geile ja er dort wo finde ich mega
cool nicht wahr ist ähnlich aufgebaut
wie wish oder keine ahnung juden keinen
plan alles möglicher krems kam und
was mich jetzt auch mal gerade
interessiert wer welches smartphone ein
geber ob ich dann ist guck mal aber hier
gibt es keine handys die mal eben 20 25
euro kosten sondern hier werden sofort
welche aber ich kann das nicht mehr
filtern
das günstigste handy und mein gott guck
mal hier hat man auf wunsch hat man für
23 euro sieht man nicht ob ich hab' ich
glaube ich für 30 euro den smartphone
gekauft und hier wollen die mir so eine
scheiße anderen gut das lassen wir erst
mal also jetzt bin ich trotzdem mal
gespannt was denn hier was schätzen sie
wie teuer sind die brautkleider wird
sich jetzt auch sagen gewundert oder so
ich würde jetzt aber um so viel geld
ausgeben aber leute so ich habe jetzt
ihr brautkleid angehen ich habe ja schon
am anfang gesagt ich werde auf jeden
fall einige sachen bestellen ich denke
mal das dauert wieder ist es ankommt und
dann werden wir das mal live antesten
gut alter kommen sollen bleibt das sieht
ja schon kasse und nun 76 ja das ist ja
eigentlich da sind davon hatte aber wir
nehmen erst mal die günstige fangen ganz
klar wir haben hier ein kleid das
günstigste kostet was findest du
hässlich hätte ich finde das richtig
geil
guck mal was ein schönes kleid das wird
dir bestimmt richtig gut stehen
das ding ist auch für schwangere frauen
ja und ich habe auch schon leute
feedback gegeben
ich denke mir so verkauft sich wirklich
so ein klein also hier muss ich wirklich
sagen das würde ich mir ja die welt
kaufen
so könnte man doch nicht irgendwie
heiraten stell dir vor du heiratest mit
diesem kleid gut
hier gehen wir ganz schnell wieder weg
ja dann würde ich sagen nehmen wir
einfach schon mal hier von irgendwie
eins das war dann wirst
sodann sagen gefällt die von denen jetzt
hier am besten ich finde ich schön die
perlen das sind bestimmt echte perlen
aus dem ozean ja jetzt aber wir haben
auch nicht ewig zeit irgendwann ist mal
die speicher gefüllt
du musst mit einem finger musste da so
leicht runter gehen das sieht genauso
aus wie das erste wo du gesagt dass
vorsätzlich natürlich immer doch das
[Musik]
aber das jetzt mal ja das finde ich auch
richtig schön so in welcher erwarte man
in welcher größe brauchst du wirst wir
nehmen uns einfach in dieser größe oder
also das soll ich jetzt nehmen okay wir
nehmen das in größe ja irgendwas müssen
wir ja hier nimmt doch dass hier gleich
für 141 zentimeter hüfte aber wir müssen
noch eine farbe aussuchen was hätte denn
leere schöne farbe einmal dass das das
oder das ich würde sagen wir nehmen ganz
klar dass das erste okay so und jetzt
brauchen wir mal hier so ein anzug für
mich in der hochzeit zwischen wie nennt
man das dann heiraten
sowas hatte ich ihnen das ist jetzt
steht hier oben alex suite weil ich bin
so sweet anzug heiraten
er ist richtig geil finde ich nicht gut
der wird mir so gut stehen ok den immo
hat linie finde ich auch gut in gelb
aber kostet nur mal was sagst du dazu
kommen wir dann gibt es in verschiedenen
farben aber ich würde einfach mal hier
wieder filtern
den finde ich richtig gut und witzig den
einfach mal bestellen warum denn nicht
so als keine ahnung so mal gucken wie
das wie das ob mir das steht so das ist
halt mal was aufgefallen dass ich gerne
mit dem trainerteam mit ich geh halt bin
halt echt so weißt du ich mache das
trait nachdem ich das auf meiner
hochzeit irgendwie in zehn jahren
getragen haben will dass jeder tragen ok
ich finde es auch schön dann nehmen wir
einfach kommune wird sich etwas
günstiger da stimmt das ist so ein
reiter anzug gut der ist hier von e on
one dream kennst du die marke das ist
ungefähr das gleiche wie wir sagt ja ist
ja gut dann nehme ich dann ich brauchte
er erwarte in m oder l
nein ich bestelle ich mein job meine
jogginghosen sind in l und das passt gut
nur bei manchen hollis fällt das zu groß
aus das ist also zudem war den herz mm
und in der farbe
war das ding ist kann man die kommission
26 49 tagen haben die ok jetzt haben wir
zwei sachen drin und rowohlt ist jetzt
noch ein kleid haben was man tut was
hältst du hier von das finde ich
eigentlich wir uns schön weil man so in
pink locker lässig kann man das auf
jeden fall rocken
okay was wir filtern das meiste wieder
neue sachen preis war für dich natürlich
nur das günstigste
ja weil ich will jetzt nicht hier 200
euro bezahlen das ist doch gut
das kostet nur 6000 dollar sie haben
schlepper und es gibt sogar einen regen
so was fühlst du gut da kannst du den
fußboden aber zwölf kilometer hinter dir
saubermachen mit dem was ist daher das
alter guck mal wie lange das ist hier
straßenreinigung kannst machen ja dann
suchte jetzt noch ein elegantes aus es
kann sich um einen drink bestellen
unglaublich
ja also eben solcher hass schon die
sehen aus wie so hier die kleider sind
ja die sehen aus wie diese staub wischen
oder das kostet 144 dollar ich glaube es
geht los
103 das wird so viel
jetzt sucht immer bitter aber ich würde
irgendwann ist auch mal der akku leer
leute ich nehme jetzt schon ungefähr 30
minuten auf das haben wir doch auch
schon
also dass jetzt auch noch ja dann hat
das auch noch da rein
ok so leute add to card welche größe
wieder in szene
nein das nehmen wir dann jetzt main 10
ok also das sind meine zehen des anderem
ein 8 das dauert auch mindestens 29 tage
ist so jetzt schauen wir uns mal die
shopping card an
wir haben hier insgesamt ok das geht
eigentlich wir kaufen jetzt die 400 watt
war mit versand 140 euro aber ich glaube
shipping kostet germany ok sogar ohne
versand also du musst nicht nur versand
zahlen
das finde ich ja trotzdem also leute
einmal dieses kleid für 39 dollar
einfach dass für 76 dollar umgerechnet
sind das keine ahnung also also
umgerechnet sind das es ein bisschen
weniger ich würde jetzt mal schätzen so
120 euro oder so 125 euro keine ahnung
ich kenne mich jetzt auch nicht genau
aus mit der umrechnung aber leider wird
es mindestens erst in 26 tagen ankommen
dann gibt es aber das video dazu ich
hoffe ihr habt da bock drauf last auf
jeden fall ein viertel nach oben da
vielleicht kann man ja gleichzeitig noch
was bestellen was warentest ist halt mal
eine neue seite gerne seiten haben wir
ja alle schon kräftig durchforstet das
war das wort leute wir sehen uns morgen
wieder am morgen gibt es neues cooles
video und machst du sehr gut gemacht
willst du noch irgendein grüßen
guck dir das war ja die wieseck snapshot
oder instagram porträt ciao